as russia cuts itself off from the west
whose side is china on
in february a document was signed which
made for uncomfortable reading in the
west the agreement signaled a deep
alliance between the nations of two
global superpowers china and russia
china's president xi jinping and
russia's president vladimir putin said
their relationship knew no limits it was
reaction to what they characterized as
nato expansion plans and growing western
allegiances they promised to work
together on ai climate change space and
control of the internet it came after
many years of a complicated and at times
uncomfortable relationship between china
and in particular the us she's
increasing doesn't have a democratic
with a small d bone in his body
but he's a smart smart guy
and it signaled something that is now
proving useful to russia a relationship
in which nothing was forbidden china's
actually quite um supportive of russia
they're
not allies but they do have aligned
interests because the chinese and the
russians they see the west both as a
problem they both see them see the west
is something they don't really like they
don't like the way the rules of the
world work
they'd like to change them
on the other hand china is immensely
stronger than russia so it's not an
equal relationship president putin which
it was he tries to pretend that he's an
equal with president xi jinping but he
isn't western intelligence suggests that
china knew about russia's plans to
invade ukraine and had asked them to
delay until the end of the winter
olympics in beijing where vladimir putin
was invited as a guest of honor it's a
claim that china denies
as russian troops made their way into
ukraine china appeared to take the
diplomatic route
does the west hit russia with sanctions
and penalties china's support gave putin
a life line
of
a loss
it is possible that the chinese would
help the russians out with a payment
system now the russians have been thrown
out of the world financial institutions
the chinese could compensate for that to
some degree they could they could take
more russian energy which they would
quite like to do if the russians can't
sell it to the west because of really
tough sanctions
and they certainly defend them just
about in the united nations and in other
world forums so with president xi
jinping effectively propping up russia's
economy by refusing to place sanctions
against them attentions turn to what's
in it for china
make no mistake china is waiting and
watching to see how this plays out the
war in ukraine could act as an example
for china if it decided to invade taiwan
beijing sees taiwan in a similar way to
how russia sees ukraine an unresolved
historical question whose future it is
theirs alone to decide
well there's no suggestion yet that the
country is planning an imminent invasion
we do know that taiwan is seen by china
as a breakaway province that will one
day reunite with the mainland
let me say this from the bottom of my
heart you have been an inspiration to
the tennis people in facing threat and
coercion from authoritarian power but
it's worth remembering that these two
countries are very different taiwan has
a much bigger economy than ukraine and
it's much further away geographically
than ukraine is from russia any invasion
would be much more difficult to execute
the thing about the ukraine crisis which
is so important is that the russians are
being pushed back not just by the
ukrainians but by world opinion
and world opinion is so um hostile to
russia and russia has become such a
pariah that in a way
it's made taiwan a bit safer because xi
jinping has realized and will realize
that the effect of this crisis
has been to strengthen the west that
said the world is now sitting up and
paying attention
the us has become one of the main
providers of arms and support to taiwan
and in response to what they perceive is
an increased threat from china a
delegation of u.s former intelligence
and military service officials has been
sent over to the island
china could well be taking comfort from
the fact that the west has ruled out
sending troops to ukraine and while the
impacts of sanctions against russia is
being felt in the west the pain of
sanctions against china will be much
more severe
for now the world waits as events play
out in ukraine but the importance of the
western response cannot be
underestimated and will have
ramifications across the globe